welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 2 episode 1 Loki has been one of
my favorite MCU titles ever and so far
season 2 is building on the high concept
humor in Marvelous Mystery even without
an appearance
from not today Miss in case you don't
remember my breakdowns of Loki season 1
when it comes to the show I hold nothing
back I literally go frame by frame not
just to point out Marvel Easter eggs but
to like illuminate the attention to
detail to decipher all visible text on
screens hidden by designers like folks
from Cantina creative who I have
interviewed to try to make myself an
expert on where and how they hide stuff
and sometimes I even illustrate abstract
time travel Concepts and theoretical
physics to connect these you would have
to kind of Bend three-dimensional space
on itself so when it comes to Loki
you're in the right place folks I'm so
glad to be back with you to experience
this amazing show every week let's go we
open with the Marvel Studios title card
now there have been several updates from
throughout phase 4 like the sides of the
r have Jane Foster Thor and moonnight
she thunderclaps from the side of the a
he remains from the Loki season 1 finale
when Loki and Sylvie first step into his
office from the elevator he appears at
the top of the a because he dominates
the AV Avengers but the latest edition
that only has shown up now on the leg of
the r hey y'all it's Miss minutes this
is a moment when she was flipping
through the fake TVA records on a fake
TVA spacecraft that would fly through
the void to stall Sylvie and it was one
of the only moments Mis minutes and ren
Slayer ever work together in cahoots
quite like this at least so far and yes
on the main Marvel Studios you see
Kamala Khan appearing in the r and then
sh from Black Panther wakana forever
appearing in the v and yes this whole
title is colored green and gold which
are Loki's colors okay we open on the
eyes of the Statue of a Kang variant he
who remains towering over the TVA just
as another statue did in the Final Shots
of season 1 after Loki was pushed by
Sylvie through a Time door from he who
remained Citadel at the end of time back
into the TVA now it's worth noting that
this he remain statue is not the one
Loki ended on in the first season that
was back in the TVA archive section this
is in the main part of the TVA from the
legal courtroom level but starting with
he who remains eyes puts us in an
apprehensive State like whatever we do
some version of Kang is out there always
watching us actually in various shots of
this background several of these statues
are scattered across this vast interior
looking out in all different directions
so we see Loki sprinting from Mobius and
the other hunters and his head perfectly
aligns with the Statue of he remains in
the background which is a clever little
way of showing how Loki considers it his
responsibility to rule the TVA and he
remains dead meanwhile Mobius and the
Hunter's heads don't align quite as well
and it's just so sad to see Loki in slow
motion turn back to look into the eyes
of Mobius his friend and realize that
this past version of Mobius has no idea
who he is the last time Loki and Mobius
were on this walkway actually was when
they really didn't know who each other
were back in the very first episode of
the series after Mobius took Loki out of
the courtroom and back then it was a
dark TVA background here there is some
light in the distance as we are seeing
the TVA in an earlier past era when he
remains still ruled it somewhat
transparently before he wiped everyone's
minds and began hiding behind behind the
timekeepers Mobius and B15 do not know
who Loki is as this would be before he
ever met them but the confusing part of
this is when Loki approached this past
Mobius and this past B15 they were
talking about this that's what 63 new
branches in this unit alone does he want
us to just let them all Branch well at
this point how are we even going to stop
it so those 63 branches must not be
referring to Sylvie rupturing the sacred
timeline in the present as we did see
mob sb15 reacting to that moments
earlier in the present day TVA a moment
that we actually see and these opening
minutes here in the present but rather
those 63 branches that they were talking
about the archive must be referring to
some other past incident in the past TVA
where the sacred timeline also really
got out of control at some point so when
Sylvie pushed Loki through that time
door from The Citadel he was going to a
past TVA where the sacred timeline had
also reached some critical state for
some reason he time slipped and neither
he nor we the viewers saw it or realized
it his temporal Aura must have
cross-wired with his past and present
self so how many times has the TVA
reached this critical mass m in its
history what was the past incident with
the 63 branches that mobus and B15 were
fretting about in The Archives it could
just be that the tva's temporal Loom
reaching a critical mass is a destined
cyclical event something that happens
again and again and again a kind of
apocalyptic Ragnarok that every era of
the TVA inevitably goes through kind of
like a bubble of a market bursting I
mean hey they must have designed those
blast doors on the loom observation deck
for a reason right so in the scene Loki
sees one of those yellow mail trucks
flying past we actually saw these in the
wide shot of episode one of the scas
series Loki jumps off the ledge and he
falls past this orange billboard that
reads timeline preservation
Administration and lands in the mail
truck numbered 435 it's kind of like
lelu Landing in corpin Dallas's taxi in
The Fifth Element we see a few boxes
flying out and you know there's some
future TVA employee who's like hey you
know I never got my package this mail
truck flies past a few other interesting
signs coercive conversation center and
variant Affairs and then from the mail
truck driver's rearview mirror hangs a
Mis minute ornament the driver panics
and clips the cheek of the he remain
statue causing it to crumble and we stay
on this crumbling for a bit as if to
suggest hey you know he who remains is
capable of crumbling and disintegrating
he is Mortal for what it's worth most of
the Kang variants we see in the quantam
Mania post credit scene also had scars
and missing body parts and various
augmentations Eugene Cordo returns is
Casey buffing the floor now you know
this is an earlier era of Casey because
his breast pocket does not have the ink
stains that he typically always has in
season one Casey said that he had spent
his whole life behind that desk so the
fact that he's a janitor now tells us
that this was from some past era before
his memory was reset when the mail truck
crashes we see it has a Mis minutes
bumper sticker reading How's my driving
report me to it's not even called this
number it's straight up report me to the
round orange Chron monitor screen has an
older era interface to show the sacred
timeline like it's blockier and
staggered and a kind of a stairstep look
to it as opposed to the smooth curved
line of the present era which might
remind you of like early early computers
before Steve Jobs insisted on adding all
this extra memory so that like the
corners of his windows could be curved
Casey removes his headphones and listen
closely calm your mind and relax yeah
it's some guided meditation recording
and I could be wrong but I'm pretty sure
this is the voice of terara strong who
also voices Mis minutes the mail truck
Teeters out the
window should be fine yeah we hear a
thud but you know we also do see that
mail truck smoking as it zigzags away so
maybe she is okay the screen falls and
cracks the floor emblem of the TVA we
see The Hourglass logo and it's pierced
by a sword because it's not just about
time these guys are slashing and burning
timelines to maintain the order there is
a significantly long take of Loki
appealing to Casey as directors Aaron
Morehead and Justin Benson use a
handheld camera to whip back and forth
between Loki and Casey just an
interesting camera style that they're
going to use throughout the episode and
what I love most about it is that it
proves they are shooting these moments
on practical sets that they actually
built whereas so much of what we see on
Disney plus is shot on the volume here
they just keyed stuff in on a blue
screen Behind These sets Loki
experiences what we later learn is
called time slipping which has a
sickening visual to it like Tom Hon's
face and his limbs contorted and
stretched from each other looking like
bubble gum it's just a very cool way of
showing a person becoming unstuck from
time to borrow Kurt vet's term for
Consciousness based time travel in the
novel slaughterhouse 5 so time slipping
is a type of time travel that I've
defined in the past as vertical time
travel in which a character slides
forwards or backwards within their own
timeline this is not to be confused with
what I've called glitching or lateral
time travel in which you hop across
different timelines or universes within
a Multiverse Loki is doing what Doctor
Strange does or Thanos does when they
use the smoother more intentional form
of time slipping using the time stone or
what Kamala Khan does when she opens the
bangle to tear a hole in SpaceTime and
go back to the 1940s but the other kind
of time travel what I've call lateral
time travel is more of like Multiverse
hopping it's what Miles Morales does
when he glitches in the animated
spiderverse movies or what Wana maximoff
does when she dream walks in Multiverse
of Madness so looki has now time slipped
into the the present where the windows
of this room are covered which means
that they might still be under repair
from that male truck crash that has now
been written in the past Casey now has
the pin and ink stains in his front
pocket and the floor crack is now there
has it always been there the crack it's
been there as long as I can remember so
to be clear that crack was not on the
floor emblem when we saw it back in Loki
season 1 so Loki really has altered
history here this idea of the past being
Rewritten in real time is a time travel
convention that we've seen in titles
like Back to the Future the movie
frequency Butterfly Effect but for the
Loki series it establishes that the TVA
is on its own timeline AIS with cause
and effect in season one Mobius told
Loki that time passes differently here
in the TV and in the comics the TV is in
a dimension called the null time zone so
we've been assuming that this facility
is kind of like time independent we
Frozen in time but no no no no things do
happen and marks are made we see Casey
is holding this orange book this is
actually the TVA guide book that we see
in the closing credit Montage that OB
references later it's in the TVA guy
book The what there's one on every day
desk at the TVA yeah he says it's a
detailed index of every mechanical
classification and maintenance routine
in each sector on each device and inside
every computer program at the TVA and OB
says he wrote it himself since Casey had
to sit at his desk for most of his
history he might have been the only
employee to read it other than OB I
think it's going to be a pretty
important book to keep an eye on in the
future okay the white on black title
with the flickering type faces returns
this was designed by the perception
Design Lab who said that they use the
fonts of the titles from every MCU movie
Loki has appeared in so that would
include the three Thor films Avengers
2012 and Avengers Infinity War some of
the typ faces are Norse runes at one
point we see an o with little horns on
it despite the changing text the color
is uniform to show that despite all
these variations we're still looking at
a Loki so back in the TVA present
present Mobius and present B15 are still
in that main Chron monitor Bay reacting
to the aftermath of sylv's decision B15
wants to tell everyone in the TVA that
the variants but Mobius is wary hey
everything you've been doing is wrong
and all your gods are dead since Loki
and Sylvie came into this as gods or
Demi Gods the delusion of of gods and
faith has really been the core of this
series since Loki worshiped himself his
God died in the very first episode
glorious purpose as he has had to come
to terms with the fact that everything
he had been doing was wrong Mobius
realizes Miss minutes is offline now we
last saw her in the season 1 finale in
the Citadel also when she was
sandbagging Ren Slayer for TVA records
we know from Trailer footage a version
of her will show up in 1893 Chicago we
meet Hunter X5 played by rafhael Casal
who we know from preseason reports and
trailer footage will also be playing the
movie star Brad wolf at the Z Premiere
in a future episode but here we see he's
also a TVA Hunter and he's kind of a
jerk he mocks Mia's love of jet skis
from that wake magazine that was on m'
desk in season one jet skis seos you
know the funny thing about jet skis
everyone thinks that it's a personal
watercraft and it's actually a brand
same way Kleenex is he's right and I
only know this because in journalism
school this was drilled into us from the
AP style guide and this always
capitalized rule also applies to velcro
and previously it applied to dumpster
though that was updated to a common term
that you left to decapitalize back in
2014 X5 reports with Ren Slayer missing
there's a new judge's Council so General
Doc and judge gamble would like to see
you both in the war room now we will
meet these two shortly but General Doc
is played by Kate Dicky Liza Aaron from
Game of Thrones and was also a first
order officer in The Last Jedi her name
dox dox might come from Mr Paradox a TVA
judge from the comics who judged
She-Hulk for the crime of warning hakai
of his impending death Mobius IM Mobius
and Mr Ora Boris who's a clone of Mr
Paradox in the comics show up in this
issue as well but the name doc could
also be a nod to the internet slang of
doxing I outing the personal information
of a private individual to get them in
trouble now I wouldn't call what general
Doc is doing now to be doxing but
something closer to like blocking or
deplatforming but hey maybe she got
those pass medals for exposing Anonymous
variants judge gamble is played by Liz
Carr and she might have gotten her name
from the TVA member Justin alons gamble
in the comics who believed the TVA
needed to move against robots called the
dreadlocks and eventually he wrote a
Broadway play called The Day of the
dreadlocks which kind of seems like what
X5 AKA Brad wolf is going to do in his
sacred timeline dream life now in this
elevator and in the War Room X5 stands
with his hands on his chest plate making
X and five Super visible like some
dumbass Who tattoos one word across his
knuckles and X5 kind of looks like XS as
in yeah this is excessive in later shots
you can actually see scars on each of
his forearms that line up perfectly with
a scratch across his chest plate which
tells me that like something might have
cut him while he stayed in this pose and
refused to break out of it yeah he's
kind of a douche okay Loki reappears to
Casey
yeah this showing its jump scares like
remember that in addition to Loki
screaming if you go through this gummy
time slip frame by frame his arm does
reach out and swipe inches away from
Casey's face so yeah the ink ain't the
only thing leaking on Casey's clothes
here luky tries to follow pres Mobius
and pres B15 to the war room they
probably heard the
rumors yeah they shot on Wilson and W
mosaku in handheld so they must have
played it in Tom hson in the background
and it looks pretty good but what
terrified Casey is just kind of a
background nothing to them they run into
Hunter D90 Neil Elise who pruned Mobius
last season and threatened the victims
of Haven Hills in episode 2 actually ran
into Neil in La one time he's a really
nice guy Loki finds the past war room
and it's empty but with a wall of five
faces of he he remains each angled in a
kind of spectrum so that it looks like
they're all looking in different
directions the score includes some
subtle vocal chanting whenever we see
the face of Kang like in the opening
seconds in the corners of this room
appear to statued heads of hunters
honoring the foot soldiers who must have
helped he remains win his multiversal
War but in the corner of the present day
war room is a female face statue which I
wonder might be for Ren Slayer who
sounds like ruled alongside he remains
in a past before he reset her and made
her a judge but we match cut from Loki
and wide in the past facing this wall to
the present-- day war room where these
he remains faces have been covered in
this timekeeper mural this episode just
does a great job anchoring us with
little visual details between the
present and the past areas of the TVA to
show us how it changed it suggests
something about he remains retcons and
create visual expository Clues to
explain how time slipping Alters history
we see the severed timekeeper head on
the present day war room table this was
the one that Sylvie decapitated and
seemed to whisper see you soon as it
rolled on the floor of the
chamber sitting at this table are judge
Gamble and some unknown sleepy judge and
general Doc and X5 sitting together now
these two seem to have a creepy
motherson relationship that B15
hilariously side eyes later it reminds
us of lady Aaron with her son Robin
Aaron sitting on her lap in Game of
Thrones but the TVA even having a war
room reminds us of Stanley Kubrick's Dr
Strange Love and it just kind of tells
us that the TVA isn't just a legal or
administrative entity it's also a
military operation with freaking
generals remember the TVA had to
violently establish a secret timeline by
winning the multiversal war and he
remains was a Kang variant who won that
war but they listen to this recording
you're all variants everyone who works
at the TBA the timekeepers didn't create
you they kidnapped you from the timeline
and it raised your memories memories she
can access through enchantment so before
this you had a past maybe you had a
family a life Loki actually said this
back in episode four the first season
you're all variants Doc's uniform is
awesome it's covered in metals and
ribbons we actually see eight ribbons
and they all have different faces that
look somewhat like the different
timekeepers but I might be crazy that
kind of looks like a mix of Iron Man
heads and Thanos heads or maybe these
are Kang variants whose timelines she
victoriously pruned for he remains on
her neck tie and on her collars are pins
with similar faces but on her shoulders
are floral esque pins that likely
connote her rank like in the US military
we use stars on the solders that
indicate what rank of general like a
onear general two star general three
star general based on this docs would be
a three star general of which in the
real world we only have 146 active duty
Generals in the United States military
on the left side of her uniform there is
a TVA hourglass badge but similar to the
UN or GH Summit meetings when someone
speaks they hit a button for the record
which lights their Corner above their
heads we are doing this by the book
under on the record the record now has a
deeper meaning to these characters as we
know he remains keeps a transcript of
everything everyone has said and will
say back in the past era War Room Loki
plays a different recording you are
quite a mod I will be proud to lead with
you you made a difference in this war
thank you for being on my team and then
Loki rewinds to play from the beginning
for us for all time always profer rley
you are quite a
so much to take away here he remains and
ren Slayer once work side by side and
she was instrumental in winning this
multiversal war in which he pruned all
of their Kang's timelines but then
something happened for he remains to
change his mind in demote Ren Slayer to
a judge who serves the timekeepers and
he calls her a Marvel which can't be a
coincidence with the next MCU film being
called the Marvels it seems to elevate
Ren Slayer to the status of a
multiversal warrior someone who could
play a role alongside Carol and Monica
in secret Wars also for us and always
could have also been the origin of the
term for all time time always when Loki
rewinds the recording to hear the full
thing this is actually after he walked a
full loop around this triangular table
and returned to the starting point time
is a flat circle but let's not brush
past this recording even being on this
tape deck here someone in this past era
the TVA was listening to it in the war
room and they paused it in the middle of
it right after hearing the name ravona
Ren Slayer I think Ren Slayer was here
moments earlier in the past and that
might be what caused this past crisis
with the 63 branches mobus and B15 we're
referring to now it's kind of hard to
tell but the orange text on that screen
with the Soundwave bar across the top
reads temporal audio chronometer and
then lists the word timeline on the
right column with three character codes
for each one and then at the bottom are
the words event date and vector and then
the date on the screen is 612 2321 now
we don't know if that date was when the
recording was made or when it was last
listen to but the TVA is supposed to be
removed from time independent any sacred
timeline date but we do know that Kang's
original scientist identity of Nathaniel
Richards began in the 31st Century in
the multiversal war could have been a
future event in our historical timeline
like in the 22nd century the 23rd
Century after which the TVA was formed
and and That Could set this listen to
date as 2321 I I don't know I have so
many questions but I do know these
details are added by designers like the
folks at Cantina creative based on
interviews I've done they're all
extremely talented and creative folks
who will often pitch long lists of words
and phrases to put on these screens for
approval by the show producers and
Marvel Studios and actually that Thanos
multiple choice question in season 1
came out of this process from the Cen of
designers we'll get back to Loki in a
moment but first we want to say thanks
to Spin Master for sponsoring this video
as well as introduce their new brand 4D
build featuring licensed 3D Marvel
puzzles 4D build makes new card stock 3D
Puzzle model kits if you're a Marvel
Super Fan who digs puzzles or wants to
add to your Museum of Marvel
Collectibles you are going to love these
everything you need to build a 3D Puzzle
comes in the Box you're not going to
have to go hunt down like a tiny
screwdriver or anything like that each
box contains a set of card stock puzzle
sheets instructions and a punch tool to
help get those pieces out the
instructions are super clear and easy to
follow puzzle sheets have letters puzzle
pieces are numbered and have colored
dots to help connect them into the right
places so we got this Muer and it took
us about 2 hours to build which you know
is less time than took to forge there is
so much attention to detail and the
puzzles are super sturdy when they're
done they are designed with replica
level detail and made for showing off
which is why every model comes with a
display stand to get a 4D build Marvel
Puzzle model kit of your own just click
one of the links in the description
below or head to Target or Amazon for as
little as $15 you can start your Marvel
Star Wars or Harry Potter puzzle
collection today so judge gamble the
more rational of these new leaders
points out that D9 testified seen RN
slayer's variant in the sacred timeline
referring to that scene in the season 1
finale where B15 and D90 confirmed RN
Slayer was once a principal at Franklin
D Roosevelt High School in Fremont Ohio
in 2018 and her name was Rebecca termin
there that was Ren slayer's comic Alias
when she was with Victor timley in 1901
I just find it interesting that judge
Gamble's personal confession of her
guilt for only issuing guilty verdicts
she keeps off the Record but then she
hits the on the record light when she
orders to pause all pruning Loki Time
Slips into the present he snatches x5's
pruning stick and he prunes the eke
keeper mural wall to reveal the he
remains faces it reminds me of hel
peeling back Asgard ceiling and Ragnarok
to show the original history that Odin
had covered up it's just interesting
that he remains didn't erase his
original Statue faces he like
wallpapered over them kind of like some
part of him knew that he might want to
come back into the light someday looki
Recaps to Mobius the events of season 1
episode 5 and season 1 episode 6 and hon
does such a good job conveying the
terror here we got to the man at the end
of
time and he made sense what scares Loki
the most is that he met someone with a
more accurate read on it than he has he
actually repeats you came to kill the
devil something he remains said to them
and Loki still doesn't know if he was a
devil or he wasn't and Loki says I wish
I had more time this is something he
says a few times actually it's something
that Marty McFly says and Back to the
Future when he thinks Doc is doomed I
only have more time a minute I got all
the time I want I got a time machine
while Loki begins this season seeing
time slipping as a curse I predict at
the end of the season it'll be a power
that he leans into to give himself more
time to do things like oh I don't know
undo sylv's decision in the Citadel to
restore he remains or to at least be
confronted with that decision when
Mobius asks who's coming Loki points to
this mural depicting several figures
shooting lasers at each other this is
actually K's comic appearance and it's
just interesting that in this present
time keeper TVA they all had these kangs
in their art under their noses we are
seeing the multiversal war that he
remains has been referring to when all
kangs fought it out and I actually think
that that's going to be a future war
that the MCU will depict in Avengers
King Dynasty Loki Time Slips in front of
Mobius and Mobius now can't make eye
contact with him yeah I saw him what is
it how does how does it look it's it
looks I mean how does it feel but when
Loki Time Slips in the elevator movus
can't help but admit it looks horrible
it looks like you're being born or dying
or both at the same time born and dying
at the same time time is a flat circle
and so this condition is like both life
events neutralizing each other out to
extract one from reality and we get this
great camera gag it's not that bad I can
handle it how does it
look this is a common gag Wes Anderson
loves to use though maybe that's just
with Owen Wilson being in it but it's
also something uh Direct like the Russo
brothers would do you know to kind of
like a third person is actually in the
room gag in episodes of ARR of
development Michael you don't want to
make the same mistake your mom made with
Buster what happened there he turned out
a little uh soft you know a little
doughy they pass a poster that reads
minimize shitchat in the cafeteria
please limit your lunch break to 17
minutes on the various prop posters that
were released ahead of the season 17
minutes is also a time limit that the
TVA automat enforces 17 a number that's
oddly specific it's a prime number
that's just kind of difficult to keep
track of or schedule your work day
around to the left of that poster is
another one the timeline won't wait for
seconds which is a solid pun with the
image of someone with a stack of plates
on his table then we see them in the
same hallway where Loki escaped to in
the very first episode where we saw the
variant that looks like Peggy Carter
this actually leads to the orange tile
wall and the check-in desk where
incoming variants would check in with
Casey but then the camera Zips down the
hall ahead of them as mobus questions
the name he remains pretty arrogant it's
like calling yourself last man standing
yeah it might be not the Tim Allen ABC
sitcom they got canceled and then moved
over to Fox hey Tim Allen is now making
bank on Disney Plus in the Santa Clauses
season 2 coming next month they pass
another poster catch a Nexus prevent a
timeline and then the timeline is only
as strong as its weakest link and then a
wall with quartets of pneumatic tubes
which is just so sad because at this
point people would just be so close to
OB just a quick elevator trip down to
him but still they would rather just
send the jobs through the tubes than
talk to him the sign inside the elevator
has a ton of text but you can make out
the words temporal radiation and some
radiation symbols since this elevator
seems to lead down only to OB and his
office is next to the temporal Loom room
he's probably one who put this up and it
just sucks that he has to be so close to
the radiation okay there's a close-up
with tube canisters with sec Ure
internal on the label there's one with a
rotting banana in it and the label
suggests is from B10 maybe another
hunter in b15s unit who's bullying OB we
in repairs and advancement and there are
more posters on the left pneumatic tube
etiquette which we get a better look of
in the official posters that details
approved usage forbidden usage that
includes sending provocative imagery
with the image of a Dear John Letter in
the tube and then punishable offenses
which includes live or dead animals and
then on the right is a poster of a
smoking temp pad temperamental temp pad
don't delay repair today and then
descending from above is kiwan as OB or
or aoris his name coming from the
Egyptian mythological snake eating own
tail time is a flat Circle K Quan after
being a child star from Temple of Doom
in The Goonies he had a massive comeback
last year winning an Oscar for
everything everywhere all at once his
jumpsuit has a patch with three gear
cogs and I just love how the wide
framing lines up the tubes to feed
directly into his head Mobius doesn't
remember the last time he saw Obie could
it be three or four 400 years what he
was my last visitor since Loki is
somewhat of a workplace comedy Obie
seems to be Steven F Roots Milton from
Office Space whom Lumberg relocates down
to the basement but he also has the
Plucky can do energy of Mr Mis or Abed
nadir and I just love him in this room
there's a jar of gumballs and a large
clock with multiple hands and another
poster on the left reads mind your head
warning about getting hit in head with
tube canisters when they fall while OB
takes one of the carbon copies and Pops
it on the skewer he tosses the other two
parts of the carbon copies on the
counter clearly no ordering system and
on that stack notice the carbon copies
are not any one color so he's just kind
of taking any one of the three and
sticking them on there looky Time Slips
into the past where OB is not wearing
glasses there's no gumball machine but
there is an old school Sprite vending
machine machine and far fewer work
tickets on the stick we get some more
West Anderson style rapid cutting and
Center framing so that our eyes don't
have to move across the frame to a new
face on the other side of the screen
during a cut this is a little technical
trick to speed up the timing of
something which is helpful for comedic
effect present OB tells Mobius that he
can't remember time slipping happening
but then
wait no there was one time is he talking
to you in the past and you're just now
remembering it wow that makes perfect
sense so what we are seeing here is a
memory forming in real time inside of
Obie's head as Loki in the past changes
his history this idea of new memories
foring is something that we've seen in
the butterfly effects from the movie
arrival when Amy Adams gives her past
self new knowledge by chatting with a
Chinese General to learn his wife's
steine words or in Lost season 5 when
the island was unstuck from time and
Charlotte begins to lose her mind as she
forms new memories of a scary man in her
past that actually ended up being
Faraday it's one of the craziest aspects
of time travel I love that they included
it here past OB says that the person in
the time Loki wants to end up in needs a
temporal Aura extractor now we first
heard the term temporal Aura in season 1
episode 1 when when Loki was being
processed and a machine would scan
Loki's temporal Aura and make sure he
wasn't a robot temporal Aura must refer
to a soul signature or source code that
transcends all of time present Loki says
that he doesn't have a temporal Ora
extractor but then we pan back to past
RNA and it's implied that Loki waited
there for hours maybe days as past OB
builds one Loki tells past Obie to hold
on to it and now it appears by present
ob's side meaning it had been there for
400 years or some amount of time
according to this history storing
objects through time is also what Doc
Brown does with the DeLorean from 1885
in 1955 and Back to the Future Part 3
and something the father and son do in
frequency to share evidence of the
murder suspect through the decades Obie
explains that they need to take the
temporal or extractor to the temporal
Loom to pull Loki out of the time stream
and movus reports wait so I need to get
to the temporal Loom so the extractor
can pull Loki out of the time stream
Owen Wilson always pronounced it
temporal instead of the correct temporal
which I will admit I for many years
would say temporal like shrimp tempora
and I blame it on Owen Wilson but Obi
warns Mobius that exposure to temporal
radiation will rip the the skin off his
body and that lowy has to Pro himself
wherever he is to free himself from time
and past Obie says have you heard about
how if you fall into black hole you turn
into spaghetti no good the less you know
about that the better so this may remind
you of what happened to one of the Scott
Lang doppelgangers in the probability
storm in Ant-Man the was quamania now
that wasn't a black hole but it does
kind of have a singularity with
similarly tricky condom mechanics at
play the visual also feels like what
Wanda maxoff did to read Richards and
Multiverse manness so they head to the
temporal Loom observation deck what I'm
going to call the loom room now the
floor in the hallway has these follow me
lines pale yellow one leading to the RNA
room and then a seafoam colored one
leading to the loom room they also pass
a hot chocolate Machine by the elevator
the floor outside the loom room reads
danger temporal radiation levels
increase exponentially Beyond this
threshold likelihood of
spaghettification increases 7,000 per
proceed with caution the loom room door
has an X with a circle in the middle
opening from the center which our writer
Gina said looks similar to the cerebro
door and X-Men and I agree OB says the
temporal Loom is where raw time is
refined into physical timeline I love
this idea that time and its natural
state is kind of raw and nebulous but
weaving it together into a causal
history of events is an artificial
construction and decision spaghetti is
also an interesting example because this
visual totally reminds me of a meat
grinder making sausage seeing the
timeline like this from the starting end
reminds me of the open-ended end piece
that Miss minut showed Sylvia and RN
Slayer back in season 1 episode 5 and
movus traces skin in the dust which is
ironic because technically dust itself
is primarily composed of dead human skin
Obi explains that Loki has to wait for
mobus to install the instra in the core
and that will turn the meter green at
which point Loki can prune himself but
because it's getting unstable he's going
to have to shut the blast doors in 5
minutes to give him self extra time to
retrofit this Loom to accept more
branches so really the stakes are set by
all of these people's willingness to
avoid pruning all these extra timelines
in rasing countless lives they are
taking the more difficult path to save
other people they haven't ever met Loki
Time Slips again and at one point the
slipped face of Loki just push his St
Mobius looking faded as hon actually had
to act out all of these spasms Having
learned from the crack on the floor Loki
uses the skin tracing to know that he
must be in the future now so present OB
loads Mobius into a hilariously puffy
temporal radiation suit with an insanely
bulky vent running in the back it's not
just inconvenient it's also humiliating
and has the same tan and seafoam color
scheme of Obie's jumpsuit Obie warns
that once the suit gives out before his
skin peels away Mobis will get very old
fitting for an Indiana Jones actor to
reference Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade when the false grare will cause
Donovan to rapidly age Obie covers the
crack in the helmet with a duct tape
like Mark Watney does in the Martian
which could seal it shut at least in
airless space but it wouldn't keep out
radiation as he trudges out on the
outside of the building are the words
for all time always which tells me that
someone must have built this so that
someone would look at this building from
the outside in oh I got to say while the
rest of Mobius is suit padding will
erode due to the temporal radiation the
duct tape is the one thing that doesn't
burn away so truly it is man's greatest
invention so in the future TVA things
have gotten even worse with the temporal
Loom crisis a PA announcer says TVA code
1127 all Personnel report to your
nearest time door evacuation point but
my question is where do they evacuate to
like all of reality is about to explode
do they go to the void is there some
backup TVA and Loki can see on this
future TVA Chron monitor Bay screen that
even more Branch timelines are cramming
into that Loom most of them saking off
into the Red Zone but it's interesting
how these lines exist as dangerous
branches before they even enter the loom
because earlier OB said that everything
this side of the temporal Loom was
supposed to be abstract time but I guess
this traffic jam has caused some of that
abstract time to actually turn into
unwoven branches that should never be
branches with nowhere to go but the Red
Zone and I do like how there's one
swooping curved white line on the left
through all of that that I'm just kind
of wondering what's going on with that
one so runs out over the future exterior
walkway and you can actually see the
background platforms have been updated
from solo Kang statues back to being
three timekeeper statues all propping up
the platforms I don't know if it's just
me but the whole vibe here the sirens
the countdown the radiation OB needing
to punch in a code on an old computer
terminal and then punch a button doesn't
this season 2 premiere kind of feel like
the season 2 premiere of lost inside the
hatch with Desmond a character who later
becomes a similarly time displaced
character the Lost season 2 premiere
totally kicked off that season with a
similar break neck pace and some bizarre
crisis with a lot of weird new rules and
it kind of feels like we're in a similar
place with Loki but Loki is looking for
a Time stick in the vacant future TDA
he's now on the legal level right beside
where the War Room was but he's drawn
now to a phone ringing we're actually
reminded of Neo in The Matrix when he
was sprinting toward an exit drawn in by
the sound of a phone ringing and Loki
and Neo both in their Sprints here
getting a painful plug in the Torso but
the elevator doors get Pride open and it
is
Sylvie
there you
are yes Natalie Holt's sorrowful violin
music returns this is a music that
played when Loki saw the film real
footage of frigga dying back in season 1
and here if you look closely a teardrop
trickles down Loki's cheek right as he
is pruned from behind so it is some
Guardian Angel knowingly or unknowingly
who delivered exactly what he needed to
survive right now but to do it they
tragically had to pull him away from the
face he most wanted to see and speaking
of teardrops when Loki burst out of that
time stream to the present he has
reflected on Mobius helmet in a way that
makes it look like a sparkle Teardrop Is
On Mobius his cheek his prayers have
been answered to two doomed Souls a
drift in a Timeless Wasteland smack into
each other and Propel both of them to a
safe haven isn't that the perfect
metaphor for what this series is all
about meanwhile a team led by General
Doc and X5 after raiding the Armory as
D90 warned about before now marches
through a Time door and you can look
inside their duffel bags to see they
contain a whole bunch of reset charges
you know those canisters so they're
probably headed out to prune some
timelines as doc said that she wanted to
earlier but they pass an orange poster
that reads your timecube atmosphere is
enough to put you at ease although the
gas inside the cube smells a bit noxious
be advised it is mostly non-toxic best
to try and relax for what is coming next
but if time cubees squeezed the person
inside what would be coming next the
closing title sequence actually mixes in
a lot of the imagery from the season 1
Credit sequence but they did plug in
some new shots of things from the new
season and some interesting Curiosities
so we start with a severed timekeeper a
robot head but then shortly after this
we see some Post-it notes on a wall with
all kinds of weird phrases there's a few
uses of the word hex than the truth what
does the monster represent hex moment
also the boy betrayed the tower keeper
also his feet silent creeping on the
soft moss covered floor pool of
deception Vapor traps in lungs initiates
dream state Parallax mortality plus
Grandeur expansiveness and amplitude
cracks appear in the fabric of reality
continuity of ancestral pilgrimage dark
Mountain mountains that could refer to
the dark mountains that was in Loki's
Asgardian song in the train in the
lamentous episode last season
Arrangements having nearly the same
energy re-echoed sound multiple
reflections of the same sound secret of
something Mountain urine's betrayal
amulets curse the cracking of water/ ice
her innocence naive keeps her safe unb
notes to her then we see a slice of
bright green key lime pie from the
automat then some diagrams of the
temporal Loom I think this is in the
orange TVA guide book with the printed
text of monitoring and maintaining the
sacred timeline and then handwritten in
cursive looks like the words throughput
mfire then what looks like a smaller
scale version of the temporal Loom maybe
a prototype of it and then we see a
bookshelf there's a book titled black
holes the end of the universe definitely
recalling OB warnings of
spaghettification other titles that we
can see on this bookcase include a copy
of Phoenix and obsidian by Michael
morock this is book about the
representation of the Eternal Champion
who's a hero who appears in many forms
across a Multiverse and he's flung from
one existence to another Michael morok
is one of the first people to like
fictionalize the concept of the
Multiverse and yeah this eternal
Champion kind of sounds like what L is
going through also part of this series
by Michael morock we see the final
program which is about a hip spy in the
60s named Jerry Cornelius who's another
manifestation of the Eternal Champion
kind of a James Bond parody but just
very surreal you can also see soless by
atonio which is described as a
thought-provoking and original
exploration of what it means to be a
sentient being we see that turn dial
phone that Loki saw and heard ringing
and here you see a blinking light for
the ss1 line on hold so let's try to
figure out what ss1 is then we see that
that hot coffee hot chocolate and ew
soup machine that they passed by the
elevator on the RNA level this machine's
awesome it has options to put milk and
extra marshmallows in it and yeah this
is actually a real machine by the way
from the' 60s in Britain then we see a
few figurines of the temporal core and
someone in that suit and I assume this
is going to be part of a future episode
there's a quick shot of that infinity
stone drawer from season 1 and then this
monkey toy I actually spotted this in
the very first season 2 teaser footage
that I broke down late last year I'm
telling you I have been tracking
everything for the show for the past
several years this monkey is a vintage
50s toy from Japanese toy maker Alps
it's made of tin and felt batteries go
into the stereo it normally comes with a
little green Sombrero but this one
doesn't have it he strums the guitar and
he sways and rocks his head as his feet
tap in those little orange shoes we see
file photos of moments from this episode
and they always put this under the
casting team s haly finin because these
are like head shots of these people that
they had cast we see OB we see judge
gamble we see B15 side eye moment and
then we see what she's looking at
General docon x5's creepy Embrace and
then Loki and then we see the 1982
McDonald's register under sofhia D
Martino's name then we see this warning
post that's actually outside the loom
room and this is hilarious life-saving
protocols check your super for defacts
before entry exposure to extreme
temporal energy will result in fatal
corporeal dehusking avoid
spaghettification then there's some
orange machine that looks like it's in
that orange room where Loki will put the
time Cube on X5 based off of trailer
footage we see he remains temp pad just
kind of sitting on his desk then we see
this other book The Zartan contingent by
someone named aded Doug PhD which we
think this might be a fake book and
that's interesting because all the other
books we saw are actually real books and
then we see the TVA official handbook
which you'll notice at the bottom reads
by Ora Boris he wrote it okay we end the
season 2 premiere with the post credit
scene 1982 Brockton Oklahoma holy
Brockton Oklahoma is a fun poll this is
where in the comics after the Ragnarok
event Thor chooses the town of broxon
Oklahoma to relocate the city of Asgard
2 and he has it initially hovering over
the ground by a few feet so Brockton
ends up being a very important location
to the Marvel Comics and that era and I
love how the title on screen specifies
branched timeline so I guess going
forward the show is going to tell us
when events are set on the sacred
timeline and when they're in branches so
Sylvie this is right after killing he
remains she enters this 1982 McDonald's
inside you can see this creepy vintage
McDonald's land tree that locations used
to have this guy looks high as hell
they're wearing the orange uniforms that
are specific to the designs worn by
employees in the late '70s remember this
is rural Oklahoma so they might be a bit
behind the Wardrobe times compared to
the big cities and suburbs Sylvie tells
Jack who's just adorable not squirrel
not possum not rats something that's
already dead and nothing with a face
please yeah having been on the run
through apocalyptic events for eons
she's used to having to hunt her own
food and I love how Jack first plugs the
new chicken McNuggets I love this detail
because as I pointed out in a video Last
Summer the chicken McNuggets were first
introduced in 1981 just great continuity
there and Jack just goes on and on with
the menu items and Sylvie says I want to
try everything yeah freaking try guys
Keith here but Sylvia really wants to
just try everything in life but but
McDonald's represents simple childhood
Joys that she never had growing up and
just trying everything on the McDonald's
menu is really her first step to try to
reclaim those Simple Pleasures that she
was denied so what can we expect from
episode 2 well we're going to talk about
that on Sunday because we're launching a
new format called Snak peek and for this
season of Loki Jessica Clemens is coming
back she and I are going to team up for
these weekly heat checks for Loki
looking ahead to each next episode you
can support our Channel by grabbing some
merch available at nerd r. shop
subscribe to all three channels in the
new Rockstar Network thank you to Noah
Chen for helping me write and research
this breakdown you can follow me on all
social platforms at eaos follow new
rockstars thanks for watching and bye
[Music]
y'all